we got a story
from from social media that's just once
again
the woke people getting away with it
headline here
on
axios
sort of a
center left
outlet
scoop
snaps snapchat snaps political data slip
okay here's how they describe it
a slip up by social media giant snap
allowed leading democratic campaigns and
party committees to unwittingly tap into
a vast repository of republican voter
data to hone their midterm ads
oops
ah darn oh i just those darn slip ups
those darn slip ups they're so
frustrating because they're always made
so unwittingly aren't they and it's just
such a weird
unwitting coincidence that the slip ups
always benefit the democrats
and they never benefit the republicans
oops oopsie-daisy
yeah the fbi got the fisa warrant wrong
and they actually didn't yeah they
didn't have any reason to spy on the
trump campaign that was a big mistake
are bad
yeah our bad we totally won't do this
again whoopsie daisy
oops hillary clinton had a private email
server where she had classified
information and at the same time she was
raising a ton of money from foreign
governments
for her own personal charity charity
quote unquote to pay her own bills oops
oopsie daisy no big deal
whoops what a slip up we won't let that
happen again
[Music]
oh by the way oops former president
trump took some documents from the white
house as lots of presidents have done
yeah we're going to kick in his door
we're not letting that slip up go
through uh-uh
no siree
now we caught that mistake we just don't
catch it when social media companies
give democrats a major advantage in the
in the elections
oopsie
i think those slip-ups are going to keep
happening they're going to keep
unwittingly happening unless we stop
them
unless
we on the happy occasions that we can
get any political power and it's always
going to be an uphill battle because
let's say the republicans retake the
house maybe there's a shout we retake
the senate
we're still not going to have the
bureaucracy we're not going to have the
presidency we sort of have the supreme
court but it's
marginal we don't have the media we
don't have big tech we don't have the
universities we don't we don't have
really any of the other power centers
but
okay we could get a little bit of the
government
we have to wield that power
we have to wield the force of big
government
you know this will make certain american
conservatives feel uneasy but we have to
wield the force of big government
against our political adversaries in a
just way in a moral way in an
appropriate way but we have to do it
because these slip-ups are not just
these slip-ups are not
appropriate these slip-ups are not moral
you can't have a good system with these
slip-ups the slip-ups aren't slip-ups
okay they're just democrats taking
advantage because they know they can get
away with it hello my lords hello my
ladies go to establishedtitles.com
knowles you have to do it this is your
opportunity to earn the title of lord or
lady and gain the respect you deserve
all you need is a one square foot plot
of land in scotland established titles
can make it happen it's a project based
on an historic scottish custom where
landowners are referred to as lards or
lords and ladies in english in your
title pack you will be bestowed with at
least one square foot of dedicated land
on a private estate in edelston scotland
plus an official certificate with a
crest your certificate features a unique
plot number with which you can see the
exact location of your land title packs
from established titles are a fun and
unique gift for any occasion there are
even couple packs because you don't want
to be a lord and then your wife isn't a
lady or vice versa so you can you can
get that for the special someone in your
life with your certificate you can
officially add the prefix of lord or
lady to your credit cards your plane
tickets even your dating profiles plus
established titles commits to preserving
the woodlands not only in scotland but
around the world they have partnerships
with global charities such as one tree
planted and trees for the future to help
with our afforestation efforts and
for every order they receive a tree is
planted
do it right now establish titles told me
that the first 200 people purchasing a
title pack using my exclusive link will
receive a plot within a few walking
minutes of mine that's right so we can
be lards and ladies together depending
on how many of you want to become a lard
or lady we can build our own kingdom
established titles is running a massive
sale right now plus if you use my code
and all you get an additional ten
percent off go to establishtitles.com
to get your gift now and help support
the channel mr nostradamus this is
smiling sam alvi i was listening to your
show while driving my kids to their
private school because we are done with
the public school system my little girl
nine years old she was listening to you
as we do most mornings and you started
talking about eating bugs and how you
know delicious they're supposed to be
and stuff like that that got her
interested that piqued her interest and
so she asked daddy
they want us to eat bugs i said oh yes
they do and then turned into a whole
conversation about how cows fart and
causes global warming and how everything
they do is just to try and find a way to
control us similar to the masks they
know they don't taste good but they're
gonna force us to eat it just so they
can say that they forced us to do it and
she looked up and said well daddy
joe biden's not gonna eat bugs is he and
i could not have been more proud it was
a moment of oh she connected the dots
she knows that those in charge aren't
going to eat bugs they're just going to
make us eat bugs or try to anyways i
guess i always knew i was going to have
that time where i had to talk about the
virgin beast my daughter but i guess it
was today but not the virgin the bees it
was the bugs in the beach
thank you for your work and uh we'll
keep listening
smiling sam alvey all right uh your
daughter is very insightful obviously uh
yes the
elites who want to get us all to eat
bugs they will be eating filet mignon
that is true
as a general rule that is true
and
there's a caveat to this
i don't think that the elites regularly
will eat bugs but i do think that they
will
temporarily or
infrequently or even as a matter of
initiation eat the bugs i think they
will do it you think of
that actress
what is her name the one who was married
to tom cruise
i forget she just did a whole video
where she came out and ate a bunch of
bugs and it was disgusting you sometimes
see uh bill gates uh came out and i
think it was he drank a glass of water
that came out of
fecal matter or some one of the just
some of all of these gross things eating
the bugs living in excrement all of this
gross stuff sometimes the elites
themselves do it
and they do it in order to shatter a
taboo they do it for the same reason
that
fraternities haze their pledges
okay they do it because
it it is a way to express and actually
reinforce one's commitment to a group
or to a secret society or to a cult
which is probably more like it
so that is the reason why are they why
are they forcing us to eat the bugs
it's
it's not that they're thinking look we
need new sources of protein and yes the
bugs are gross but that's what we have
to do in order to get the protein it's
actually the other way around they're
saying man we have a taboo in our
culture against eating bugs
so if we want to upend the culture we
have to eat the bugs
we actually we have to do it because it
is so gross
that will
break the taboos these taboos and
standards to find cultures and so when
you when you shatter them and you
reorder them you are reordering the
culture in a very very profound way
that's a lot of what's going on with the
bug eating and the protein and the
efficiency and getting all the poor
masses to eat cheaper sources of protein
and uh and creating
even greater inequality between the poor
and the elites that that goes along with
it but i think the taboos are really
central to it i'm so glad you liked that
clip now if you want to get even more
clips
would you please ring that bell
subscribe get the notifications we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you